so obviously it's best for all of us if
this goes as smoothly as possible
let's dress that's the operative word
here I've said that you can't just pop
by overnight minute you said hey dandy
Beth it's my son my sister and her
husband took care of our Mayas in prison
and now they won't share custody it's
not my clients who are going to hear the
word manslaughter attached to that name
I was at least I'm good behavior a year
though I give you my phone number my
well yet what's with the tenure gap in
the employment history I really need
this job I'm trying to get my son back
is really messed up I'd be surprised if
she ups he's that kid again this girl I
was representing didn't fit the picture
of what a good person is supposed to
look like not thing up neither do you
don't I get a drink pretty much all I do
is drink with strangers
so you'll do it's like a different kind
of name there's a monster out there and
I can't see it and I can't fight it see
what the trying to do this trying to
beat you all over here and say that to
me again
understandable let's not understand I
hope they won't let me see my son no I
don't ever touch me again okay
where does this go in your mind when you
were planning this whole thing out where
is the best place that this goes
my spirit has had too many tests I don't
think it can take anymore
this is the point where you say yes your
honor
[Music]
shut up super shut out no bad things
happen to people who don't deserve it
everyday and it's gonna happen over and
over again
[Music]
I just need one person to take a chance
on me
[Music]
you
you